the bite administration
losing complete control of the surge of
migrants rushing our southern border
but who do they blame
what the administration has inherited is
a broken system
at the border the 11-year high for
crossings
without documentation of the border was
in the middle of trump's presidency this
idea that it's
joe biden's election that has prompted
more people to show up is belied by the
actual
facts joe biden inherited a huge mess on
immigration
what we are seeing today is the
consequence of
four years of dismantling every system
and place
to address this with humanity and
compassion
as we saw yesterday the talking points
went out and they were clear
let's bring in fox news contributor and
retired acting ice director tom home and
tom good morning
uh you heard it they say that they
inherited a mess at the border and
that's what we're seeing
look the facts are they inherited the
most secure border i've seen in my
career
pete which has spanned over three
decades that is a fact
in 2020 the alien children that the
numbers were down 70 percent from year
prior
uh illegal immigration was down 50 to 80
percent depending on what month you look
at
and last month joe biden's policies has
created a 300
increase in ailing children what's
really disturbing is you got senator
chris murphy on
being interviewed by chris wallace who
is the chair
of the homeland security committee and
he doesn't know what's going on the
border
either he doesn't know or he's lying
about it which is
neither one's a good look for the chair
of the homeland security committee whose
job is to secure the homeland well i got
news for you senator murphy
the homeland is not secure the border is
not secure because the bite
administration has undone all the
success of the trump administration
you got a job to do educate yourself
give me a call
i'll tell you how to fix it but you
can't go on national tv and say this is
president trump's fault
do you think they think they know and
they don't care do they not are they
willfully blind to it what what is the
reason why
they would look at something like this
and not rationalize that it's a crisis
and then blame trump because because
they can't admit to the american people
that they plan this crisis
when joe biden made those promises
during the campaign
of ending ice detention and they remain
in mexico program
uh uh give amnesty and daca and
healthcare when you make those types of
promises
you know they're going to come so they
can't go on national tv says
we sold out america to win an election
joe biden can't say i voted to the left
to get votes and gave up the security of
the border
again the most secure border we've ever
seen under president trump
uh tom the dhs ordered fema which
usually deals with as you know floods
and storms and other major disasters to
the border
is that an admission right there they're
dealing with the the flood of migrant
children when you call in fema
absolutely actions speak louder than
words and their mission statement i
wrote it down
helping people before during and after a
catastrophic disaster
or crisis so sending fema to the
southern border
guess what all the cars are on the table
now it is a disaster
and it is a crisis and look under bite
now i'm just thinking
what on on the comments member chris
murphy i've never seen anybody wearing a
trump shirt
coming across that border but we've seen
a lot of them wearing a biting t-shirt
letting you know
this is because of joe biden his
policies period
catastrophic disaster in the mission
statement you call them in and then you
won't even call it a crisis
it says everything you need to know tom
holman thank you so much appreciate it
thanks for